hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm thoroughly exasperated with
everything that's going on my life and I
hope to actually say some sensible
things in this episode like hi how are
you doing I'm not okay I'm borderline in
tears at the [ __ ] that's ahead of me
and you know what it's okay I don't mind
it this one's not as bad as companion
spring but it's still the [ __ ] that
gets to me like this would this could be
a fun well-designed level if Frost
didn't inject his hatred into it it's
like you know how in Star Wars they said
unleash your hatred yeah Ross did that
Ross unleashed his hatred all over this
just hatred hatred all over just covered
in hatred oh so much goopy hatred
everywhere that's that's what Ross did
when he was making this level he just
sprayed his hate all over it and that's
all we have left to go by is just hate
non-stop unadulterated stickiest [ __ ]
hate oh come on oh come on son [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you
flower would have been great to have on
this date but I don't have the power so
[ __ ] your mother thank you for dying
quickly I guess I won't have the flower
which means that the other one with the
spiky shell is gonna be a bit more
difficult maybe I could God [ __ ] what
why how [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you such
[ __ ] such steam god dammit
finally what why why why not have them
why not have them I hate this
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I need the
helmet ok I'm ok
[ __ ] never mind [ __ ] it Yolo [ __ ] we're
gonna go without it we're doing it live
we're doing it live we don't need that
let the mother hump or burn ok so oh
well then I guess that's cool too so the
thing is you can't let yourself be
trapped by this or you'll die
nope nope that is quick death come on go
it was right there there's no excuse for
that it was right there I was there I
was inside it I was inside it there is
no excuse for that that's where the [ __ ]
am I going this such [ __ ] there's no
excuse for that this it's no excuse it
shouldn't know better this game should
[ __ ] know better it knows better
god damn it when is this [ __ ] thing
gonna [ __ ] behave talking about this
game like it's a bad dog stupid [ __ ] you
- [ __ ] you man
okay so with that being said we're gonna
get through this with the flower this
time thank you very much
why why why why right then I had the
flower I had it it was in my hands it
was in my [ __ ] hands you clod stop
just stop stop huh I'm so angry it may
not look it I may just look tired but
that was bound to happen cuz they didn't
have what I [ __ ] needed and what I
[ __ ] needed was not even the flower
it didn't even give me the goddamn
flower it took everything they took from
me everything and that gave me nothing
300 right friends
okay we got this time we got this time
definitely got it definitely definitely
got it right in there
good good good good good good good good
we got it we got this this is the one
this is the winner baby this is the
winner I feel it in my bones I feel it
in my bones good you didn't want to hit
me you didn't want to come near me yeah
well this is [ __ ] well [ __ ] me then
at all my efforts and everything I've
ever done [ __ ] em [ __ ] em all [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you that's what I say to
you that's what I say there yo then come
in guns blazing oh [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
dead yeah there we go I thought who's
gonna go very differently gun blazing oh
okay whatever you know if the next one
is doesn't matter cuz I get one anyway
if I just stay up here and goes over to
the other side which he's not gonna do
is he [ __ ] you know what I'm just gonna
stay here - never mind I'm gonna just
yes yes oh god oh god I'm staying up
here [ __ ] you I don't know what's going
on but I'm gonna stay up here
long as it takes okay
I hope I'm hitting them I don't know if
I'm hitting them yeah what does I do I
don't know what I did I don't know what
I'm doing am i hitting them
I hope I'm hitting them oh I'm so cheese
in here but I don't care I don't care I
don't care I don't care I don't care I
don't care I don't care yeah come on
bring it on with your stupid breath did
he die is he dead oh oh oh god damn it
oh oh no do not oh no no no no no no no
no come on be nice be nice okay I got
all the time in the world I just got to
do this oh I got all the time in the
world oh good I didn't want to go then
anyway [ __ ] all right
I don't know
oh god why yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes oh oh oh that feels good
oh that feels good oh it feels good oh
it feels good
Oh guys congratulate yourselves give
yourselves a round of applause oh we did
it oh we did it oh we did it
I beat it but I feel I lost a bit of my
soul I lost my entire soul Eric it's
okay all right
oh thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna take a nap after this
one I'm gonna hug chica I'm gonna look
at the stars at night I'm still gonna
call my mom bird call my mommy mommy
come by Bobby and then I don't know but
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for believing in me this whole
time
so I don't know if you guys want more
Mario maker I don't know I could play
more I'm sure there are even harder
levels than this that are probably more
better designed but we'll see about that
so if you have any suggestions put them
down thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video